>>
I'm Harmut Reinke and I'm the Regional Director
for Turkey, Middle East and Africa for DuPont
in that region. The question is about role
models. I truly believe that role models are
very important for that part of the world.
Leadership has to be help up. Young people
have to be brought to the work cycles. Society
has to see role models as the ones that are
helping to shaping politics, economy and overall
shift of the modern economy. So for Middle
East building up role models or having an
opportunity for people to become role models
is absolutely important. When we look at all
the expatriots that are coming into the region,
they may not be the right ones because they're
not coming from the right cultural background.
So a role model, the benchmark for the locals
have to be their own people. They have to
develop their own future and convince the
world here on the right track in the Middle
East.